I'm curious your thoughts on
on story
I was watching your show I've noticed it
from just telling stories on stage and
just watching other comedians tell
stories I've noticed the way that I
react when I see stories I know it's a
way that like when you're with a group
of people and one person begins a story
the group just shuts the [ __ ] up now if
the story sucks eventually people will
move on but everybody's given like a few
seconds
if the story is set up right
is there something biologically wired in
our brain to like pay attention to this
to react in a way like even with the
Cuttlefish story you told did you notice
the energy shift in the room I mean at
that moment I'm just in it as you know
is like on stage like uh I felt a shift
man yeah I mean people got I mean I love
like we're still learning things but
we're learning it through story which is
like I think it's a more impactful way
yeah yeah so without question story is
the most powerful way to communicate
information yeah just no question I mean
why I wish I knew here here you know
it's not often I'm lost for words yeah
this is one of those cases I don't we
can't point to a specific biological
mechanism yeah I wish I could tell you
it's because of this that and the other
thing but here's a couple of hard
biological findings that are really cool
if we were to each listen to the same
story
in separate rooms and we start the story
at different times maybe even on
different days and I track your heart
rate your heart rate my heart rate is
and his heart rate
and then we were to look
your Baseline heart rate would be
different than everyone else's and vice
versa but the adjustment but the
adjustments map almost that's it
perfectly this was a study that was
published in cell reports last year and
I love this because and we're coming up
on the holidays here and like you never
want to timestamp a podcast this way or
like but the or Time Capsule this way
but you know when we read story and we
hear story together we synchronize our
physiology this is this is one of the
coolest studies ever and so there's
something about sharing the same
physiological response and look it
doesn't all boil back down to sex but as
long as we have an opportunity to talk
about sex in a healthy context
what is sex okay sex is reproduction in
some context not others yeah it's but
you're you're taking your physiologies
and you're saying to some extent I'm
gonna let you control my physiology and
I'm going to control your physiology in
a consensual way right that's consensual
sex and when we listen to story whether
or not let's say I listen to a story you
know Eastern European Time 9 p.m and
you're listening to at 8 A.M and then
we're totally out of sync but our heart
rates map onto the same Contour so I I
so that's the best answer this is
awesome in terms of data and that's it
that paper is one of my favorites let's
work on this because I'm really excited
about this as as I've started to do
bigger venues you know when we're on
tour we've been doing it starts at
you're doing comedy clubs 300 seats then
you're doing a thousand two thousand
radio cities six thousand and I started
to go okay the way that we hold
attention in bigger spaces has to be
different
and I don't think that everything has to
be stored I think that you need to like
mix things up but I have noticed it's so
funny that you said that but I have
noticed that story can wrap up a room of
many more people when it's 30 40 people
we can do premises quick ideas potshot
jokes Mr X and that kind of stuff but
holding ten thousand
ten thousands you need everybody to have
similar reactions at similar times and
I've been thinking about this for a
[ __ ] year straight going how do I do
twenty thousand how do I hold twenty
thousand and have everybody waiting
for that moment for the laugh to happen
and you tell me right now that when
people listen to story they all have the
same reaction in those same moments
opposed to like just giving an opinion
or like stating a premise some people
might disagree they might get turned off
they might be upset right some people
might find it hilarious but a story even
if it upsets you you're still reacting
with all those other people that's right
that's shared reaction it's like waves
on the ocean we're all going up and down
together at the on the same on the same
boat and before he started doing movies
with The Rock who was the biggest tour
in comic in decades yeah Kevin Hart yeah
Kevin Hart's doing [ __ ] the link
that's how you fill that space and
that's how you get everybody in the same
thing I mean you look at you look at at
Chappelle you know he's he's been able
to do these like massive venues these
incredible Storyteller oh yeah and that
last special he's talking about his
friend from San Francisco yes uh from
San Francisco weaves that through yeah
Dance I mean we used to gather and you
know people would hunt together people
would cook together people would sing
together people would dance together
story telling I mean it's been said
where the storytelling species no it
seems like I mean it seems like a a
cheat code almost to be honest to like
convey information I mean I even look at
like you know sometimes when I'm trying
to get inspiration I do it outside of
Comedy like I'll even look at like
politicians who were very like
charismatic and like why are they
charismatic what are they doing and like
I was watching an old Bill Clinton
interview regardless what you think
about [ __ ] Bill Clinton he's
undeniably charismatic right and that's
why he was able to be president of the
United [ __ ] States right despite
exactly despite all the [ __ ] that people
not forget just as a point I'm still
amazed and then like listen politics
aside like I know people that still love
him despite the fact that he got caught
lying and they're just like they kind of
forgave him almost because he forgave
himself it seemed like he forgave
himself and so people forgave him I mean
there was no Wilder [ __ ] he was accused
of let's put it that way cheating is the
least physician yeah I'm very uh and I'm
not playing uh Dodge here but I'm very
naive when it comes to your house
because it just confuses me because I
feel like there's no data it's worse
than alcohol for recovery
but the point is I was watching him one
of these late night shows and he was
asked a question about the climate or
something like that and he didn't just
give a day to answer he told a story
he's like you know what when I was in
South Carolina I remember once and
there's this guy and he came up to me
and he talked to me and everybody just
gets immediately wrapped into this story
about and he somehow proves that it's
affecting coal miners or something like
that I'm not exactly sure but through
the story and had like a a little funny
punch line at the end and I'm like wow
that's the greatest Santa I've ever
heard on this
it was absolutely amazing I'm like this
is a superpower yeah learning how to use
that but the fact that everybody's
reacting in the same moment that's how
you fill those spaces that was so
helpful
um that's so helpful I'll pass you the
study please you have a degree in
Psychology from our Alma material the
study is almost the same when you think
about it I'm just
[Laughter]
um but uh in any case it's a really
interesting study because the first one
that I'm aware of that really sees a you
know different rooms different times of
day different subjects same story and of
course you're going to get people to
have
greater and lesser reactions to a story
some of you like it more or less and we
have different attention but it all they
lay out the curves and they just map
onto one another you go oh my goodness
uh you know I saw this when I saw why we
want to watch shows together and I mean
this like you know every Sunday there
would be like the HBO show that comes on
at nine o'clock whether it was Game of
Thrones or
excuse me it doesn't matter whether it
was AMC with Mad Men it didn't matter
but like we do want that group
experience we do want to watch our show
the movie theater it's like being in
there with all these people and a movie
is the story yeah for an hour and a half
we're all just in the same place you
want to feel that we want to have those
reactions we want to be scared and have
everybody go huh together yeah the story
is the thing that wow I didn't think
about like that a story is something
that
creates what do you say shared
physiological we could think about it as
resonance you know it's like a feeling
that we're kind of one in the same we've
we felt the same about the same things
even if we don't know it's got somewhat
subconscious remember I saw um Joe Rogan
um no last name needed but Joe Rogan uh
two comedy at the Vulcan Club down yeah
he does that submission sometimes in
Austin and he's got this bit I won't
even try and repeat what it is but it's
hilarious but he's leading you down this
path and you're thinking
oh no he's not going there but you kind
of know where he's going yeah but you're
not sure and it was amazing because I
was like wow I'm not sure if it's
leading to a surprise or a confirmation
of where I think he's going yeah and
then I realized like it doesn't matter
we are all online and then of course the
the end is great and I don't even want
to cue people to it because if you
haven't heard for the first time it's
it's amazing it's amazing the third time
because I've seen it three times
um but his ability to spool out the
narrative because you have to keep
people on board because we all know that
guy or that girl who starts a story and
then you're like Ram like oh my God
where's this going like is this going
you know that that's often because
there's no information Gap like there's
nothing that we want to know that's
right creating that information Gap our
curiosity spikes and we're like all
right well take me there like it's the
horror movie right you're like what's
down the hallway right where's somebody
following her is somebody outside you
got to create that and I think the
people that don't tell the stories well
they just create no information cap they
give you all the information you know in
great courtroom room You Know Drama is
really about bringing the I mean I have
friends who are lawyers who do criminal
court and civil court a ton is on the
line and they create a narrative about
the other person they use the person
actually to fill in words to create the
narrative they want so they create this
argument using other people's words I
mean lawyers are masterful they're
really good ones are masterful at
getting a narrative into the juries none
of that that's that'd be great just
seeing how they build narrative build
curiosity Alex used to work in the court
system so yeah I would see it out and
the best lawyers were the best
storytellers like everyone's just like
we're just like engaged and it's like
yeah real it's so notable difference
when there was someone who was really
good oh yeah and then the bad ones are
the ones that are just giving you the
info they're just like ah this thing
happened at this time and this is why
you know I'm in the health and something
you got to sell me on it and would you
see someone who you thought might have
been guilty would you see like wow the
reaction from people change yeah and
that's why having a good lawyer is so
important because it's like even if the
person is innocent or guilty if the
other lawyer can convey it better it's
like you can get that person off it
might be a reach but is that why the
media is so powerful because they write
the story yeah once they craft the
narrative and get everybody into it it's
it's set yeah I mean you know I think
about I used to I try and avoid like
serial killer crime stuff because it's
dark and it's out there and like I don't
want to focus on that now but I was
living in Davis when uh there was a
whole Scott Peterson Lacey Peterson
murder yeah she was pregnant it was it
was really around me at one point they
discovered body parts in this uh
canister not far from where my lab was
at that time and it turned out that was
a guy working at the coroner's office
who was taking his work home but he
wasn't involved in the murders it wasn't
her body but there were all these things
happening and then he died remember then
Scott Pearson dyed his hair ran from
Mexico he had this thing with this woman
who was this massage therapist and they
literally had footage or of him saying
oh yeah I'm here in Paris under the
Eiffel Tower and there was at the vigil
for his dead wife you know the media did
a masterful job of piecing together all
these things that basically set him up
and I from what I understand he's guilty
right I don't know it wasn't there but
I wasn't there but the uh good album but
the you know they piece the other this
thing of like all these behaviors
created the story of this guy who was a
liar a cheater a guy who would try and
disguise himself and leave but they
never actually got him directly to
confess or anything like that so they
create this narrative that you go like
this guy killed his wife and his unborn
child and he should go to prison forever
maybe he got a death penalty I can't
remember I think they reversed on it
anyway the point is that like the media
created a narrative about him yeah well
right now Liz Holmes is going to get um
sentenced in a few days right theranos
yeah company with all these blood tests
and the fabricated stuff she's been
found guilty I've watched uh what is it
um bad blood I think is the you know the
story around her is so powerful that you
know and it's gonna be really
interesting to see what happens so I'm
very curious to see what happens but the
media lives on information they live on
the story and yeah it's like why haven't
they sentenced her yet like let's get
the show on the road yeah um
now she's a mother an expecting mother
with a kid so now there's a sympathy
weave and like you know and and so
listen I don't know who did what but the
media is masterful at doing this
politicians on the other hand at least
as far as I can tell are just trying to
navigate the next 12 hours of the news
cycle yeah and make someone else look
bad so that the lens is off them yeah I
think this is why really good people
don't run for for office there are a few
good ones out there like I'm a fan of a
few of them but most it's just kind of
like protect oneself and point fingers
at everyone else for 12 hours yeah 12
hours 12 hours it's pretty awesome it's
a survival game and then just yeah no
Visionaries like I mean the right now
I'm I think we're really we you know we
need Visionaries we need people who can
get out there and and tell us also it's
like who would do it right like you
think about what you go through like the
scrutiny like even our friends what
they've gone through like Joe being in
his position and having so much power
and influence and then just putting his
name behind a candidate and then
immediately the next day having an
onslaught of media narratives
like look so imagine that's you like
imagine you're already a billionaire I
look at all these guys who are
independently wealthy and they're like
well why don't why doesn't uh well Jeff
Bezos run for president it's like why
would that because he loves his life
exactly it's like it makes your life
horrible they're gonna look at what your
kids do they're gonna do everything they
possibly can to make you radioactive and
just destroy any symbols of happiness
you have we have a system where it
actually behooves you to already be a
piece of [ __ ] before you run I think
everyone who runs through office should
make their second speech
all the things that they did wrong that
they can remember
and then ask whether or not people still
want them to run yeah and then and let
people like post to that list yeah let's
not waste the time yeah it's just like
here's all the terrible stuff the Eight
Mile like Eminem
I think everyone would be better off
yeah I think everyone we do need good
people I really hope that somebody
listening to this is like gonna like
bite the bullet and just you know run
let's hope maybe you yeah not never
gonna happen I think you have more
influence in culture like I I don't know
I like being a part of culture I don't
want to be a part of politics I don't
want to be a part of like telling people
what to do I want to be a part of like
reflecting on what people do and what we
love and to me that's way more fun than
making rules you know what I mean no way
I mean it doesn't appeal to me at all I
ran for office in the seventh grade I I
lost I started skateboarding so much
quick team sports after that and just
yeah no I'm like do my own thing and
science is fun because there are
definitely rules but there are rules
around trying to figure things out yeah
and no one becomes and stays a scientist
if they don't really want the truth yeah
because it in the end like there's no
real incentive for figuring out stuff
that's not true yeah every once in a
while you hear of these people it turns
out that 90 of the time when people
commit scientific fraud they're medical
doctors who get into science they're not
pure scientists and guess what they get
caught and they do it again they get
rehired and they do it again I have a
friend who who knows this area like
Sport and he loves he's brilliant he
loves telling stories about all these
people get caught doing terrible things
like you'll falsifying it and they do it
again and again and again I think it's a
compulsion I think it's like the it's
like the people who they're just
delusional I think I think the game for
them becomes trying to get one over on
people it's not really about why are
medical doctors want
egos
um doctors come in two forms and I think
there are many many excellent doctors
who have incredible beds I may really
care about their patients and then there
are a lot of them that would like to be
well known and famous and it's very hard
to be well known and famous in that
profession and doctors who go into
science oftentimes get a little bit of a
of a boost because their training is
unique and special and um yeah for
whatever reason that they're when you
look at data for application more often
it's medical doctors turn scientists
than pure scientists wow um but but I do
want to say that again not for political
reasons but most doctors probably 99 of
doctors are very well intentioned and
very you know just trying to help in
whatever field they can oftentimes very
unhealthy themselves I see that a lot I
look at some of the doctors you know
Stanford is different to be fair like
people pay more attention to their
health I think but sometimes I see like
I've seen dentists with bad teeth yes
wow so it's weird right and people
always go you know it doesn't compute
yeah but anyway that who knows